(audience applauding and cheering)
- You look beautiful.
- You look amazing.
- Oh man.
- [Kelly] I know.
You look amazing.
That's nice.
- So, so cute.
- And the chain, the
necklace, I like it all.
- You love?
- Have y'all ever met?
- No.
- No. We haven't.
- This is our first time.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- What a stylish gentleman, my God.
- I wanna say,
- And the hair.
- you guys look so beautiful.
- Oh, thank you.
- You didn't get the memo
about the forties dress,
but your outfit is still great
(Kelly and Jordan laugh)
- We were just talking
about Christmas stuff.
So what do you do for Christmas time?
What's your thing?
- Well, every Christmas I go to Dallas.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Oh yeah!
- I go to Dallas. Yeah.
- Are you from Oak Cliff?
Is that what I heard?
- I am from Oak Cliff.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yes.
- I'm here from Fort Worth.
Yeah.
Yeah!
(high fives)
- Yeah!
- We're family.
- I know! I was like, wait, Oak Cliff.
I was like, I know Oak Cliff.
That's amazing.
- That's dope.
- Yeah.
- So you go back there every Christmas?
- Yes, every single Christmas.
I'm actually, I was born in Dallas.
I'm from LA.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- I lived here since I was five.
- You came out there it's still Texan.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
(both laugh)
But you know, every single Christmas
my whole family lives there, so,
- Yeah.
- Yes. I'm there.
- That's so fun.
- Every Christmas.
- Texans know how to do food, y'all.
- Oh.
- Especially at Christmas time.
- Man. Well, that's,
- I hear you have a special drink, though,
that you like at Christmas time.
- Yes.
- We have this in common.
- Eggnog.
- Why would you not wanna drink it?
It's amazing.
- Yes, it's great.
- Yes. Well, we heard.
- It's great.
You like eggnog?
- I love eggnog.
- Thank you.
- A lot of people
- I will not tolerate
- don't like eggnog.
- eggnog slander.
- You know what?
- Oh!
- Can I?
- Okay!
- Wait, I'm sorry.
- Can I?
- What?
- Can I wait, I'm sorry.
(audience laughs)
You got champagne.
- I got my own.
(Jordan and Kelly laugh)
- Wait, I got a one up this.
Have you ever like heated
it up in a saucepan,
and then, like, and put
like a little Amarula in?
- No, never done that.
(Kelly vocalizes)
- [Kelly] Mm.
- Oh, okay.
- It's good.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And then you have a very merry night.
- Not just, not a clean riff,
for no reason.
- [Jordan] Mm.
- My God Kelly.
- Just, just,
(audience laughs)
It's, that's what
it does, to my soul.
(Anna exclaims)
(Jordan laughs)
Eggnog with Amarula.
Like it's, coffee with Amarula,
anything with Amarula is really good.
Well, we know where Anna
stands on New Year's Eve.
So what about you?
Are you like a party, or
are you chill at home?
- Party.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Actually from Dallas.
I make sure I'm back in LA.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- You know, so I can party.
- Because people in Dallas are home.
Like, "Hey,
- You know, at home,
- the ball's droppin'"
- you know.
(Anna and Kelly chuckle)
- My mom likes to stay there,
you know,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
be with my grandmother,
and I'm like, I gotta go to the club, so.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'll be right back.
- So you're, like, out late.
- Oh yeah.
- I'm
- I'm sorry, this is a
really silly thing to say.
Clubs are open on New Year's?
- Oh yeah. Hell yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- I'm sorry.
That's wonderful.
- So congrats on Bel Air.
- Thank you.
- That's awesome.
(Audience applauds and cheers)
- So, I have seen every
episode of like the first,
you know, the first time around.
- [Jordan] Oh yeah.
- like Fresh Prince.
So, like, did you ever see
the original Fresh Prince?
- [Kelly] I'm just saying you're young,
so, I'm just saying.
You're young!
- I watched, last night,
I watched Fresh Prince.
Every single night to go to bed.
- Oh, the re-run thing.
- I watched
Fresh Prince and Martin. Yes.
- Oh, Martin,
- Yes. it's still,
That's my,
- Oh my God, I love that one.
- Yes. I love that one.
- Oh
That was, those are my two
favorite shows of all time.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- And I think that, it's just
so interesting that I got,
you know, this role literally
is my favorite show.
I've been watching it ever
since I was like 10 years old.
- Yeah.
- Because it's a syndication.
So even though,
- Yeah.
- It's old like it's still relatable
and everything and you know.
- I don't know why I said that.
Cause I watched, I Love
Lucy and I wasn't that old
but I watched re-runs, yeah.
(Jordan laughs)
When I was a kid.
(Jordan cheers)
Yeah, yeah. You watched the re-runs.
It's such a fun show.
- [Jordan] Yeah, yeah.
- and this one's different.
This is what I love about it.
- [Jordan] Yes.
- It's different it's more serious.
- Yes, I mean, that was also,
man a blessing because
when I got the audition,
Little story, when I got the audition,
I watched Fresh Prince every single day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So they were like,
okay, we have this audition
for you to be the new Jazz
and Fresh Prince, and I was like, nah.
And they were like, wait, why not?
And I was like, dude, we
already have Fresh Prince out.
Like, are we gonna do another sitcom?
Like,
- Yeah.
- You know, I don't
want it to be like that.
And sometimes you know,
what's for you is for you.
And my manager was like,
nah, like you, you gotta
do this audition.
So I read the script and then
when I got the script I said,
oh, this is different.
- Yeah.
- Oh, this is like a whole dramatic,
- Which is smart.
- retelling
and it's, we don't step on anybody's toes
and we have our own thing,
we have our own identities
even though we have, you know,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- playing the, you know, characters.
But, no biasness.
If you haven't seen it, go watch Bel Air.
It's great.
(Anna chuckles)
- No, I love the twist on it.
(audience applauding)
I think that's really important.
It's different.
- Yes.
- So your character runs a record store
and your co-star Coco Jones is
performing later on the show.
- [Jordan] Yes, yes.
Are you into music as well?
- I am. I'm not into music as they are.
Like, you know, I have my
favorite artist and stuff.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Coco is a sanger, not a singer.
She is a sanger.
(Kelly gasps)
And so, you know,
- Yeah.
- That's, that's her,
- That's the only kind of
singer I like to listen,
- You know? Exactly. If you can sang.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She can sang.